Let's talk about the demi-gods, who are each
and all the direct offspring of Queen Marika.
There was Godwyn
Morgott
Mohg
Radahn
Rykard.
Ranni.
Miquella, and Malenia, Blade
of Miquella.
Malenia, Blade of Miquella
all of these demi-gods had fallen from grace
by the time the shattering occurred, but in
this video I want to mostly talk about the
origins of these characters.
Who these demi-gods were, before the fall.
...and some of these demi-gods fell a long
way, indeed.
Before he became this unsightly mess Godwyn
the Golden was quite the heroic figure.
He was born of the promising union between
Lord Godfrey and Queen Marika, and achieved
great renown for his bravery in one of their
wars: The War of the Ancient Dragons.
This war began when Gransax, a great ancient
dragon, rained calamity down upon Leyndell,
marking the only time in historical record
that the Royal Capital's walls had fallen
It's not clear why Gransax first attacked
- but, fortifying themselves against lightning,
the knights of the Erdtree weathered his assault,
and Gransax was defeated However, this was
only the beginning - and a bitter war against
the Ancient Dragons was to follow.
During this war, the Erdtree Sentinels had
an epiphany: that "The only way to truly protect
the Erdtree, was to become dragons themselves".
And so, despoiling the corpses of their foes,
the grotesque sentinels served the Erdtree,,
- but fought with the claws of the enemy instead
In the end, the Ancient Dragons were routed
once again.
In a graveyard of swords by the Stormcaller
Church, the end of the war is commemorated.
Here, we learn that, during battle, Godwyn
the Golden defeated Fortissax, the mightiest
dragon of them all.
However, he did not kill Fortissax.
Instead, he befriended him.
And it was in this act, that the powers of
the ancient dragons truly became a part of
Leyndell - after all, "only those loved by
dragons can survive the ordeal of cladding
their bodies in lightning".
So from an unlikely friendship, an ancient
dragon cult was born in the capital city,
and the knights of Leyndell learned to worship
the dragons, and wield their lightning.
Lansseax, sister of Fortissax, even took human
form to better commune with the knights . it
was officially decided that worship of the
ancient dragons did not conflict with belief
in the Erdtree... -
and it was all thanks to Godwyn - commander
of the dragon's "Golden" lightning, and a
true child of the Golden Lineage.
But now...let's talk about Morgott, and Mohg,
the Omen twins who were also born of Godfrey
and Marika's Golden Lineage.
First, what is an Omen?
Well, to put it simply, an Omen is an "accursed"
child, seen as "impure", as they are born
with horns on the body and face.
When this happens, the correct thing to do,
culturally, is to cut off the horns of the
Omen, an act which usually causes them to
perish It's pretty messed up.
Now some Omen do survive this process - and
some are even given the Omen Cleaver, a weapon
awarded as a tool of war, though these weapons
are bestowed with a readiness to take them
away
We find one such Omen in an Erdtree camp upon
the Altus Plateau.
Before you fight it, you might have noticed
another Omen writhing in its sleep.
It's said that Omen see evil spirits in their
nightmares, and I think this Omen is dreaming
- haunted, by the vengeful spirits of its
accursed kin.
This brings us to the Omenkillers, horrifying
butchers of twisted conscience, who wear horned
masks that make a mockery of the Omens' nightmares'
. These butchers hunt Omen, and amputate their
horns.
The first Omenkiller was named Rollo - a famous
perfumer who imbibed a physick that rid himself
of emotion, so that he could better perform
his tasks . Remember, many Omen have their
horns excised when they're only babies.
That's..definitely disturbing enough to warrant
a emotion-killing physick, in my book.
However, if the Omen is born of royalty, then
their horns are not cut off, but they are
"kept underground, unbeknownst to anyone,
and imprisoned for eternity".
By way of example, you would have seen all
kinds of horned Omen confined to the sewers
beneath Leyndell.
But why are the Omen considered to be accursed
in the first place?
What's inherently wrong with being born with
horns and great strength?
Well..it's important to remember that this
curse might only really exist in the context
of the Golden Order - after all, those afflicted
with omen horns are not able to return to
the Erdtree for rebirth, and are born outside
of its grace.
And why does the Golden Order disavow the
Omen?
Well it's hard to say for sure, but it's my
working theory that it's to do with the crucible.
According to this ancient incantation, "horns"
were once an aspect of the Erdtree's primordial
crucible, where all life was once blended
together.
. And with the exception of a couple of crucible
knights in and around Leyndell, we know the
Golden Order has started to distance itself
from anything that touches upon the crucible.
While things like horns, knots, feathers and
scales once grew on the human body and were
considered signifiers of the divine , now
they are disdained as impurities, as civilization
has "advanced".
We learn this from the knot, scale and feather
talismans - all of which are guarded by Omen,
or dropped by Omenkillers, no less.
Unfortunately for the Order of the Erdtree,
these once-divine "impurities" seem to crop
up in some births, whether they like it or
not.
Almost like it's a genetic trait..as if it
touches on the crucible at the root of the
Erdtree.
And so...you have to ask - is it really a
curse to be born as a graceless Omen?
Well, as with most curses in these games,
I think that depends on your perspective.
In any case, Mohg and Morgott were Omen royalty,
and thus, were born into a wretched mire far
below the earth, horns and all.
Here, they were kept under the strictest confinement
- each of them with charmed shackles that
were covered in roots , and bathed in golden
magic.
It seems very few people were supposed to
know that they even existed .
Morgott, for his part, renounced and despised
his accursed Omen blood - but his brother
Mohg embraced it.
Deep underground, Mohg stood before an outer
god - a being called the Formless Mother,
who craves wounds, and was capable of bestowing
power upon accursed blood.
In this moment, Mohg's accursed blood erupted
with fire, and he became besotted with the
defilement that he was born into.
Here, deep below the earth, he would go on
to build a dynasty of blood, in reverence
of a mother - something that it seems he never
truly had.
As for Morgott, he was born into the same
accursed fate as his twin brother - but despite
not being blessed with grace, he loved the
Erdtree all the same, and even took it upon
himself to crawl out of the sewers and become
the Erdtree's protector , when the Erdtree
needed him most.
In the end, he rightfully became the Omen
King, and Lord of Leyndell.
Omen or not, he was, after all, born of Godfrey
and Marika's Golden Lineage.
Of course, the marriage between Godfrey and
Marika would be ended, and before long, Marika
remarried with another man - a champion, named
Radagon, who Marika calls her "other half"
. He became second Elden Lord, and the King
Consort, but he also brought with him three
children from a previous marriage with a Carian
Queen named Rennala.These children were Ranni,
Rykard, and Radahn, and they became demigod
stepchildren after Radagon's (re?)Union with
Queen Marika.
Possessed of his father's flaming red hair,
Radahn was fond of its heroic implications,
and considered himself to be born of a great
champion.
Yet, he had also long looked up to another
man - Godfrey, the First Elden Lord: Queen
Marika's first husband, and the Lord of the
Battlefield.
But Radahn wasn't just the son of Radagon
and an aspiring Lord of the Battlefield..he
was also the son of Rennala, who was head
of the Academy of Raya Lucaria, and Queen
of Caria.
So, as a Carian royal inclined towards sorcery,
Radahn bent his will towards mastering gravitational
magics.
Rock Sling...Gravity Well..Collapsing Stars..these
techniques were taught to him in Sellia, the
Town of Sorcery...all so he would never have
to abandon his beloved but scrawny steed.
That said, before long, his powers would soon
be put towards a more...cosmic purpose than
simply allowing him to ride his horse.
Radahn was taught gravitational magic by an
Alabaster Lord - a member of "a race of ancients
with skin of stone who were said to have risen
to life when a meteor struck long ago".
And when his lessons were complete, Radahn
said these chilling words:
"I thank you for your tutelage, for now I
can challenge the stars".
And of course, he did conquer the stars - and
the very constellations would be halted by
his strength.
But of course..you have to ask..why?
Why was it necessary to conquer the stars?
Well I have a couple of theories.
Theory 1 is that this was done in self defense.
After all, according to the Sword Gravestone,
Radahn was "protecting Sellia".
What's more, Gravitational magic has "destructive
power", AND many gravitational beasts are
proof of that destructive power.
A being named Astel had even come down to
the Lands Between in the past, and destroyed
a place called the "Eternal City".
What's more, Sellians are "descendants of
the Eternal", positioned right above the Eternal
City underground - so there is an argument
to be made for Radahn purely defending Sellia,
here.
But it's possible for Radahn to have fought
in this conflict, AND to have made the first
move as well.
So this is theory 2 - that Radahn conquered
the stars as a preventative measure, in service
to the Greater Will.
According to a set of Astrologer items, the
night sky cradles fate.
There's even a banished sect of people called
the "Nox", who live deep below the earth who
live in eternal anticipation of the coming
age of the stars, and their Lord of Night.
Long ago, these people invoked the ire of
the Greater Will.
So it would make sense that those in service
to Greater Will might have sought to arrest
the stars, and put an end to this fate.
What's more, Radahn was a huge fanboy of Godfrey,
and seems to have more loyalty to the Erdtree,
than to the moon.
Most tellingly however, the Telescope says
that "the fate once writ in the night skies
had been fettered by the Golden Order".
Surely this is referring to Radahn's actions,
and it levels the blame blame at the Golden
Order, rather than Radahn himself.
But putting Radahn's motivations aside, it's
a fact that the stars were held back, and
that this had great consequences for many..especially
for the rest of his Carian Royal family.
Let me explain.
The fate of the Carian royal family is guided
by the stars.
As is the fate of Lady Ranni, first heir in
the Carian royal line.
But General Radahn is the conqueror of the
stars.
Who stood up to the swirling constellations,
halting their movement in a smashing victory.
And so, if General Radahn were defeated, the
stars would once again resume their movement.
As would Lady Ranni's destiny.
Lunar Princess Ranni was the daughter of Radagon
and Rennala, and sister to Radahn.
Interestingly, if you look at her true body
atop a divine tower - it looks like she might
have also inherited the red hair of Radagon.
Cool detail.
But unlike Radahn, she quite clearly took
after her mother more, who was Rennala, head
of the Carian Royal family.
The house of Caria has a storied history - one
that seems to go way back to the astrologers.
In the Carian Manor, we find one of their
treasures - the Sword of Night and Flame.
It reads "Astrologers, who preceded the sorcerers,
established themselves in mountaintops that
nearly touched the sky, and considered the
Fire Giants their neighbours".
Rennala herself was an astrologer, always
chasing the stars, in her youth.
Then, she met the full moon - and, in time,
the astrologer became a queen, establishing
the House of Caria as royalty.
Caria appears to have had a matriarchal heirarchy,
with multiple princesses, and Carian knights
that served as their retainers.
Now, however, there is only one princess:
Ranni, daughter of Rennala.
And at the time of her birth, she would have
been set to inherit quite a lot of power indeed.
For the Carian Royal Family was at its height,
and her mother was not only Queen - she was
also head of the academy of Raya Lucaria,
having bewitched them with the enchanting
power of the full moon.
Leading the young Ranni by the hand, Rennala
guided her daughter to a meeting with a moon
of her own.
What Ranni beheld was cold, dark, and veiled
in occult mystery.
A Dark Moon - a sort of twin to Rennala's
own full moon.
You can even see both of these hanging in
the sky, if you stargaze from the heights
of the Moonlight Plateau.
Another who guided Ranni was a character called
the "snowy crone", who the young Ranni encountered
deep in the woods.
When you look at Ranni, it's actually the
likeness of this snow witch that you're seeing
- as the doll that now houses Ranni's soul,
was modeled after her..probably as a sign
of respect.
Clearly, Ranni looked up to this mysterious
woman.
She became the girl's secret mentor, and she
even knew about the dark moon - teaching the
young Ranni to fear it as she imparted her
cold sorceries.
So what do these moons represent?
Now this is just a theory, but it seems that
moons act as guides.
The lost black moon of Nokstella, for example,
"was the guide of countless stars".
What's more, Ranni and Rennala were heavily
influenced by their moons: Rennala's moon
bewitched the academy that she became the
head of, and Ranni's Dark Moon, for its part,
also imparts "wisdom" and leads a "voyage",
in the Age of Stars ending.
They could even be outer gods.
And yet, for all this guidance, Caria - and
Liurnia as a whole, have experienced steep
decline.
Radagon betrayed the House of the Moon.
Radahn locked the stars into motion.
The Academy Town is flooded to the North,
Caria has been ruined in the west, and the
stars and moon have gone their seperate ways.
Nevertheless, Ranni, last princess of Caria
- remains - carefully setting new plans into
motion.
Sibling to Ranni and Radahn was a man named
Rykard, Lord of the Volcano manor.
There is evidence that Rykard was friendly
with his siblings - he conspired with his
sister Ranni, and there's even a portrait
of Radahn hung in the Volcano Manor..as well
as a portrait of Rykard himself - before the
fall.
Item descriptions mark Rykard as stern, heroic,
ambitious...and blasphemous.
A part of this blasphemy was opposing the
Erdtree . which drew many knights to his banner.
For Rykard believed in taking by force..
just as the gods did..and clearly, many believed
he would usher in a new age.
The armor set of the Gelmir Knights reveals
to us what were once very loyal soldiers.
The crest of red feathers are there symbolize
Rykard's pedigree as Lord Radagon's son, and
the emblem upon their chestpiece stands for
a lord with lofty ambitions.
However...
As Rykard delved into the ancient secrets
of Mount Gelmir, he came across the Immortal
Great Serpent, an ancient deity that aligned
with Rykard's ambitions.
And so, Rykard fed himself to the the Great
Serpent, so that he might devour, grow, and
live eternally.
Alas, this was too much for his knights, and
they believed that their masters heroic aspirations
had degenerated into mere greed.
So, they searched desperately for a weapon
with which they might halt their lord - and
they found it too - a Serpent-Hunter spear
that had been used to hunt the immortal serpent
in the distant past.
But it was too late.
As the lord lost his dignity, so too did these
knights, lose their master.
Not that it bothered Rykard.
Next, we need to discuss Malenia..and Miquella.
These two were twins, as they were born TOGETHAA
No..fuck off Rykard.
Not your section.
So - as you know Radagon's marriage with Rennala
did not last.
Afterwards, he returned to the Golden Order,
and became Queen Marika's consort.
But what I haven't yet mentioned is that together
(TOGETHAA), they were blessed with two demi-god
children.
Malenia, and Miquella, the so-called "twin
prodigies".
Now, in the last lore video, I briefly proposed
that these two twins were born after the shattering,
after Radagon and Marika had merged together
to become a single god.
However, I've changed my mind.
To put it simply, there's just too much proof
that Malenia and Miquella were a force influencing
the world long before the shattering took
place .
Anyway - both of the twins were born afflicted.
Miquella was born "afflicted" with eternal
youth..and Malenia, for her part, was born
"vulnerable" to Rot.
Interestingly, Malenia's Scarlet Rot..is actually
an outer god, and old legends of the Scarlet
Rot have persisted in the world for generations.
This Outer God, like many others in the game,
seems to have an "order" that is able to be
imposed upon the world via an empyrean vessel.
According to Gowry, the "Order" of Rot is
resplendent - a cycle of death..and rebirth.
Kind of like the lotus flower, that blooms
anew from the mud.
I..actually have art of this, hanging in my
home.
I always loved the symbol of it.
I have lots of art hanging now actually, and
I'm going to talk about it at the end of the
video.
Anyway ~
So Malenia the Empyrean was "vulnerable" to,
and "afflicted" by, the Scarlet Rot.
There was said to be no cure, and while fire
and consecration seem to be somewhat effective
at warding it off, Malenia would slowly lose
her physical self to the Rot.
Interestingly, old legends of the Scarlet
Rot have persisted in the world for generations
..and we learn more about the Rot god from
the Blue Dancer Charm.
"The dancer in blue represents a fairy, who
in legend bestowed a flowing sword upon a
blind swordsman.
Blade in hand, the swordsman sealed away an
ancient god — a god that was Rot itself".
Specifically, this god was sealed away in
the stagnant water downstream of the Ainsel
River.
And wherever rot appears, the Kindred of Rot
appear too - pests, and servants of Rot.
Servants that have now been forsaken by Malenia,
their new goddess
This blind swordsman with the flowing curved
sword went on to become Malenia's mentor.
So technically, it's him we have to blame
for this god damned attack.
The Prosthesis-Wearer Heirloom tells us more:
"A talisman engraved with a scene from a heroic
tale.
Though born into the accursed rot, when the
young girl encountered her mentor and his
flowing blade, she gained wings of unparalleled
strength".
Aesthetically, it makes a lot of sense that
flowing waters would counter the effects of
rot.
For "just as still waters turn foul, stagnation
turns to decay.
Thus, warriors must remain ever drifting".
Indeed, Malenia does resist the call of the
rot.
She does this through sheer will and sense
of self, and only when she is truly pressed
in battle will she abandon those things, and
bloom into the goddess within.
Malenia's first bloom was during her fight
against Radahn - a last ditch effort that
would forever taint the land of Caelid, and
cripple Radahn.
Whatever she was fighting for in this fight
against Radahn, somehow, it was worth this
terrible act.
In general terms at least, it's clear that
Malenia was fighting for her brother.
Apart from the times where she relapses into
the Goddess of Rot, she is known as the the
Blade of Miquella.
She actually goes to great lengths to tell
you this, I don't know if you heard.
Despite being the toughest boss in From Software
history, she fights for his right to godhood,
not her own.
In Malenia's own words, her brother Miquella
"possesses the wisdom, the allure, of a god
- he is the most fearsome Empyrean of all".
For his part, Miquella did a lot to earn his
sister's dedication - not the least of which
was inspiring her armour and a prosthetic
of unalloyed gold.
And it's not just his sister that loved Miquella
- many people did.
The Bewitching Branch is an item you can use
to turn enemies into temporary allies, and
it reads "indeed, he has learned very well
how to compel such affection".
But hey, maybe he bewitches them for good
reason.
After all, Miquella is a character that is
defined by the things that he does for others.)
For his father Radagon, Miquella fashioned
and gifted a fundamentalist incantation called
"Triple Rings of Light".
Radagon then returned the favour, gifting
back an incantation called "Radagon's Rings
of Light".
These show some of Miquella's positive interactions
with his father and Golden Order fundamentalism.
"And yet, the young Miquella abandoned fundamentalism,
for it could do nothing to treat Malenia's
accursed rot.
This was the beginning of unalloyed gold".
So..what is unalloyed gold?
Well, an alloy is a composition of metals
- so unalloyed gold is pure gold, essentially,
with no external mixtures.
Fittingly, Miquella bent a lot of his efforts
towards creating an unalloyed gold needle
- something that could ward away the meddling
of outer gods.
Specifically, this needle was crafted for
his sister - to ward off the Rot god, and
forestall the effects of the incurable rotting
sickness .
We see the bond between the siblings when
we visit Miquella's Haligtree - with a statue
of a one-armed woman embracing a child.
In this place, we see the biggest example
of Miquella's benevolence - the Haligtree,
and the society built into the brace that
supports it.
This is a promised land seen as a salvation
to many who are shunned or persecuted - provided
they can find the path here
Like the other Empyreans, Miquella seems to
have had the will within him to create a new
order - and it's an order that is somewhat
modeled on those that came before.
But the biggest thing, is that his Haligtree
is inspired by the Erdtree - but the difference
is that Miquella's Haligtree is said to be
accepting of all, even those that the Erdtree
shuns.
Miquella himself was once embedded inside
of the Haligtree, watering it with his very
own blood since it was a mere sapling.
Tragically, however, he was ripped out of
this womb during the shattering - and his
Haligtree ultimately failed to grow into an
Erdtree, becoming a misshapen husk instead.
But that's the story for another day.
There's also a ton of cut content to do with
Miquella.
Honestly, I've only really laid the foundations
for all the Demi-gods stories' with this video,
and there's so much yet to come..so subscribe,
and ring the bell -
Though there is one more thing that I'd like
to mention before I go.
So...Miquella and Malenia each have their
own butterflies.
Malenia's is the Aeonian Butterfly, which
inhabit the Swamp of Aeonia, and are rumoured
to come from the wings of the Goddess of Rot
herself.
We confirm this when Malenia blooms during
her fight against us, and of course, she bloomed
previously in Aeonia, in her fight with General
Radahn.
And I think it's fair to say that Miquella's
butterfly is the Nascent Butterfly, which
"appears as if it's just emerged from its
cucoon for its entire life".
This is a reference to Miquella's eternal
youth, and his cuccoon in the Haligtree.
But there is of course, a third butterfly.
The Smoldering Butterfly.
An eternally burning butterfly that serves
as kindling.
Now bear with me..but it's my theory that
this butterfly is a reference to Melina, who
the Blade of Calling calls "the kindling maiden",
and "the one who walks alongside flame"..
At any rate, Melina is almost certainly the
Daughter of Marika - we learned this long
ago from looking at her name in the game's
files, and can further infer it from her dialogue
as it refers to mothers.
Now, this is still just a theory - it's something
that you can choose to believe..but if you
do choose to believe it, then the fact that
she might have her own butterfly alongside
Miquella and Malenia might help to confirm
her specific parentage - that being Radagon
and Marika, which is to say, Marika herself
alone, I guess.
Honestly, Melina as a character has only become
more mysterious since the game was released,
and I'm really only scratching the surface
with this theory.
Speaking of times before Elden Ring was released,
back then, I commissioned this piece from
a renowned artist named ma-ko..and now I'm
excited to reveal it for the first time!
This storybook scene is heavily inspired by
the early scenes of Elden Ring, with a red-haired
protagonist, spirit companions, a mount that
looks like Yakul..and a few more hidden details.
This piece, and all my other prints are now
available over at Spring, where you can now
buy them fully framed, and ready to hang.
The frame itself is in a nice black satin
finish, and you can even opt for a white border
which looks pretty classy on certain prints.
I think it's a cool way to support the channel
and artists, and to get something in return
as well - so check these out, if you're interested.
But thank you for watching, and I'll see you
next time.